ein unmenschliches gefängnis an der
ostsee
in diesen kalten grausamen mauern konnte
man verrückt werden
eine riesige bunkeranlage hoch oben in
den französischen alpen
[Musik]
sowas in den bergen gebaut
eine geister brücke mitten im dschungel
wenn ich im brasilianischen regenwald
unterwegs wäre würde ich so einen beton
giganten als letztes erwarten
und eine künstlich angelegte insel
mitten im hudson river
diesen ort spec lemon zu bezeichnen wäre
eine untertreibung
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
diese bauten aufgegeben manche sind orte
lebensgefährlich verseucht wer hat sie
errichtet und wie und warum wurden sie
ausgemustert
[Musik]
im südosten brasiliens umgeben von den
gipfeln des gebirgszugs maradona steht
ein beeindruckendes bauwerk
[Musik]
mitten im regenwald taucht sie aus dem
morgennebel auf eine straße die ins
nichts zu führen scheint
es ist neblig wolken ziehen herein und
plötzlich taucht diese riesige
betonkonstruktion vor dir auf sie
scheint direkt aus dem dschungel zu
wachsen und verschwindet dann wieder
[Musik]
als hätte ein riese einen gigantischen
legostein da hingelegt
im brasilianischen regenwald unterwegs
wäre würde ich so was als letztes
erwarten kommt eine riesige verlassene
brücke aus beton das wäre wirklich sehr
seltsam
wer hat das mächtige bauwerk am fuß des
berges errichtet und wo führt das hin
[Musik]
in den 50er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts beginnt die brasilianische
regierung mit dem bau einer küstenstraße
die br 101 erstreckt sich auf einer
länge von knapp 5.000 kilometern von
nord nach süd sie wird brasiliens
längste fernstraße
dieses teilstück der br 101 liegt
allerdings mitten im urwald weit weg von
den berühmten traumstränden der
[Musik]
brasilianische ingenieur newton
cavaliere kennt die geschichte der
fernstraße
die br 101 verläuft entlang der
brasilianischen küste an der grenze
zwischen den bundesstaaten rio de
janeiro und sao paulo gibt es
seltsamerweise eine unterbrechung und
zwar genau da wo die serra do mar
beginnt
dieser abschnitt wird zunächst nicht
gebaut
während der siebziger jahre allerdings
investiert die brasilianische militär
regierung viel geld denn die
infrastruktur
die pläne für das unvollendete teilstück
werden wieder hervorgeholt
[Musik]
ursprünglich sollte die straße oben in
den bergen verlaufen das brachte aber
einige unlösbare probleme mit sich sie
brauchten einen plan b durch den
regenwald schwierig aber wie wäre es
knapp über dem regenwald
bereits existierende schotterpisten sind
die basis das mineralölunternehmen
petrobras hat sie zur wartung seiner
pipelines angelegt
die wirtschaft boomt in diesen jahren
man spricht vom brasilianischen wunder
warum also nicht etwas größer denken und
mit hilfe bereits existierender tunnel
und brücken eine abkürzung quer durch
den dschungel baum
wichtigstes teilstück des ambitionierten
projekts ist diese brücke der petrobras
viadukt
[Musik]
er soll helfen die 50 kilometer lange
küstenstraße rund um die halbinsel
überflüssig zu machen
man kann sich vorstellen wie anstrengend
die bauarbeiten mitten im regenwald
waren es war heiß und feucht und
wimmelte von
wir boten ließ sich nur schwer
ausbaggern die arbeit musste immer
wieder abgebrochen werden heute sieht
man die löcher nicht mehr weil alles
zugewachsen ist
der bau einer 40 meter hohen und 300
meter langen brücke ist unter diesen
bedingungen eine echte herausforderung
für die brasilianische militärführung
aber lohnt sich der aufwand aus
strategischen gründen
die machthaber haben ein umfangreiches
atom programm entwickelt und dabei
spielt dieser autobahnabschnitt eine
wichtige rolle
[Musik]
das teilstück war sehr wichtig denn das
kernkraftwerk angra wurde genau am ende
der 4 101 errichtet
es war also in richtung norden ans
straßennetz angebunden
nach süden hin aber nicht
[Musik]
angler liegt an einer
erdrutschgefährdeten bucht zwischen rio
de janeiro und sao paulo für den fall
einer nuklearen katastrophe wird ein
fluchtweg gebraucht deshalb soll die
straße fertig werden bevor angra ans
netz geht
[Musik]
verschiedene teams arbeiten an
unterschiedlichen teilen der strecke
einige sind schneller als andere aber
alle stehen vor komplizierten aufgaben
und die uhr tickt
bei einem komplexen straßenbauprojekt
das aus tunneln flachen abschnitten und
brücken besteht fängt man normalerweise
mit den schwierigsten elementen an die
sind am teuersten und aufwendigsten von
dauern am längsten
deshalb ist es ein guter plan zuerst die
schwierigen teile fertig zu stellen und
sie erst danach mit den einfacheren
abschnitten zu verbinden so wird das
gemacht auch wenn es vielleicht
unlogisch klingt
[Musik]
beim bau hat es viele probleme
sie mussten tiefe schluchten überwinden
manche pfeiler sind 40 meter hoch
und das alles für die relativ kurzen
strecke von 300 metern
[Musik]
da kann einem vieles das leben schwer
machen das fängt mit dem feuchten
untergrund an der von wurzeln durchzogen
ist
wie kann das baumaterial angeliefert
werden wie sollen die creme dahin kommen
außerdem ist es heiß und feucht und das
macht die arbeit noch schwieriger
die hohe luftfeuchtigkeit bringt
allerdings nicht nur nachteile mit sich
[Musik]
bei diesen bedingungen ist es sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass der beton zu
bröckeln beginnt
die feuchtigkeit sorgt dafür dass das
material gut erhalten bleibt
die
trotzdem wird die brücke nie an die
bundesstraße angeschlossen
die fertigstellung des nahe gelegenen
atomkraftwerks verzögert sich bis weit
in die 80er jahre hinein
brasiliens wirtschaft leidet unter der
ölkrise
die straßenbaupläne werden verworfen und
die brücke sich selbst überlassen
eine brücke abzureißen ist oft teurer
als sie zu bauen deshalb ist es meist
leicht da sie einfach stehen zu lassen
die petrobras brücke ist das
überbleibsel einer gigantischen
fehlplanung aus den tagen als eine
wirtschaftskrise den traum vom
brasilianischen wunder zum platzen
bringt
mit dem atomkraftwerk angra wird die
brücke nie verbunden stattdessen wird
sie der natur überlassen
[Musik]
inzwischen ist sie ein teil des
regenwalds geworben kaum jemand kommt
noch hierher
petrobras feiert ist in die brücke hat
sich dem wald förmlich aufgedrängt
es ist daher nur recht und billig wenn
die natur sich nach und nach einverleibt
was eigentlich nie dorthin gehört hätte
[Musik]
an der küste estlands in tallin steht
ein gebäude mit einer düsteren
vergangenheit
[Musik]
vier hektar groß drei stockwerke hoch
feucht kalt und unwirtlich
in dieser wasser festung wurden einst
5000 menschen gefangen gehalten
das erstaunliche ist die dreieckige form
die an die freimaurer erinnert dafür
gibt es keine erklärung
juni aus der nähe betrachtet fragt man
sich plötzlich wozu all der stacheldraht
im inneren finden sich kilometer lange
flure am verfallenen zellen entlang
darin wird einem schlagartig bewusst wie
kalt und abweisend dieser ort ist es war
nie vorgesehen dass sich dort jemand
wohl fühlt
wozu wurde das gefängnis in tallinn
gebaut und wer saß hier ein
[Musik]
im verlauf des großen nordischen krieg
meldet das russische zarenreich anfang
des achtzehnten jahrhunderts erstmals
ansprüche auf estland an
in der folgezeit versucht der große
nachbar immer wieder dass strategisch
günstig gelegene land zu annektieren
von island aus hat die russische marine
zugang zur ostsee und damit auch zu den
feinden im westen
nach stalins machtübernahme kommt
estland erneut unter russischer
herrschaft mit harter hand setzen die
sowjets ihre interessen durch jeder
widerstand wird brutal niedergeschlagen
[Musik]
die udssr war ein totalitäres regime
eine opposition wurde nicht geduldet
für die führungseliten der baltischen
staaten gab es nur ein schicksal
sie wurde weggeschlossen und der
schlüssel entsorgt
nach 12 jähriger bauzeit wird die
festung 1840 fertiggestellt nach dem
ersten weltkrieg kämpfen die ersten
wieder einmal um ihre unabhängigkeit und
machen daraus das gefürchtete gefängnis
unter den sowjets wurde batterie später
zu einer außenstelle des kgb dem
gnadenlosen geheimdienst der welt
es war die hölle
batterie wird zu einem mahnmal des
schreckens ab 1945 werden hier tausende
inhaftiert und zum teil wie vieh
gehalten
der estnische historiker martin andrea
weiß welche bedingungen hinter diesen
mauern herrschten
dieser ort ist ein synonym für den
kommunistischen terror der in estland
ausgeübt wurde wir wissen nicht wie
viele menschen diese auf jetzt hier
insgesamt eingesperrt haben aber in den
großen zellen saßen 80 häftlinge
es gab nur eine toilette und
sie bekamen nur 1 lag das war's das ziel
war den gefangenen ihre menschlichkeit
zu rauben sie sollten das gefühl haben
genau das hier verdient zu haben
es war ein grässlicher ort
ehemalige premierminister politiker und
diplomaten wurden in battery
festgehalten von hier aus ging es
entweder weiter nach sibirien oder
direkt ins grab
batterie dient als zwischenstation für
tausende gefangene
anschließend werden sie in die
sibirischen gulag verlegt wo hatte
zwangsarbeit auf sie wartet
deportierten tausende ersten nach
sibirien bloß weil die ersten waren
in katar herrschen schlimme bedingungen
[Musik]
kabarett war wie eine mischung aus der
kalten halle sibiriens und den
knallharten methoden moskau
und das mitten in tallinn
der unmenschliche umgang mit den
gefangenen aber bleibt nicht folgenlos
es spricht sich herum dass in
gefängnissen wie papa gefoltert wird
der russland hass in der estnischen
bevölkerung nimmt immer weiter zu und
im untergrund formiert sich der
widerstand
eine besondere rolle spielt dabei diese
gruppe diewald brüder
der name wald brüder tauchte im baltikum
während der russischen revolution von
1905 zum ersten mal auf dabei handelte
es sich vermutlich um lehrer und bauern
die sich vor den russischen besatzern in
den wäldern versteckt später wurde
daraus eine echte politische bewegung
partisanen aus allen baltischen staaten
waren bereit ihr leben im kampf gegen
die russische besatzungsmacht zu opfern
nach der sowjetischen invasion während
des zweiten weltkriegs gehen in estland
lettland und litauen mehr als 50.000
weit brüder in den widerstand immer
wieder greifen sie aus dem hinterhalt an
und fügen den sowjets empfindliche
verluste zu
um nach sibirien geschickt zu werden
genügten schon geringere vergehen als
sich den wald brüdern anzuschließen
jede art von aufruhr wurde hart bestraft
der kgb war grausam und rücksichtslos
und versuchte den widerstand gegen die
sowjetische herrschaft im keim zu
ersticken
[Musik]
im battery gefängnis gab es einige
prominente häftlinge ein anführer der
estnischen partisanen bewegung der
schreckliche angst so sein spitzname
wurde hier festgehalten ehe die sowjets
ihn anfang der 50er jahre hinrichteten
zahlreiche mitglieder der wald brüder
enden in patara dazu verdammt ihr leben
in einzelhaft zu verbringen
[Musik]
die sowjets waren sehr gut darin die
gefangenen zu verunsichern
es gab kein tageslicht und unregelmäßige
mahlzeiten
so verloren die häftlinge jedes
zeitgefühl
in diesen kalten grausamen mauern konnte
man verrückt werden
während des kalten kriegs unterstützte
der westen partisanen gruppen die sich
gegen die soft jetzt auf lehnten die
weit brüder erhielten unterstützung von
britischen mi6 und von der cia
hatten großes interesse am erfolg der
wald brüder sie wollten verhindern dass
sich der russische kommunismus weiter
ausbreitete
aus batterie jedoch gibt es kein
entkommen nur drei ausbruchsversuche
sind dokumentiert keiner davon
erfolgreich
[Musik]
der kgb sorgt dafür dass das gefängnis
nahezu ausbruchsicher ist
[Musik]
es war unglaublich schwer hier
rauszukommen die mauern waren über zwei
meter dick und drinnen gab es ein
praktisch unüberwindliches
sicherheitssystem um es überhaupt zu
schaffen hätten die häftlinge die hilfe
der wachleute gebraucht
[Musik]
1991 findet die letzte hinrichtung in
paris statt es ist das jahr in dem die
sowjetunion auseinanderbricht
auch nach dem abzug der russen bleibt
batterie ein gefängnis noch bis 2002
verbüßen verurteilte hier ihre strafen
heute ist das gebäude eine ruine die an
dunkle zeiten erinnert
[Musik]
ein mahnmal das an die sowjetische
unterdrückung erinnert in gewisser
hinsicht können wir hier immer noch
hinter den eisernen vorhang blicken
eines tages wird es hier womöglich
bedeutend freundlicher aussehen es gibt
pläne den komplex zu sanieren und ein
museum zu eröffnen in erinnerung an jene
die hier eingesperrt waren
[Musik]
in new york city an der mündung des
hudson rivers lag einst das tor nach
amerika
[Musik]
doch die berühmte freiheitsstatue
empfing nicht jeden mit offenen armen
für viele endete der traum von freiheit
zunächst auf der benachbarten insel
[Musik]
dort stehen 22 roten backsteinbauten mit
dramatischer vergangenheit
diesen ort als beklemmend zu bezeichnen
wäre eine untertreibung
er ist total unheilig
an den wänden wächst wein manche fenster
sind vergittert es ist totenstill
mal abgesehen von gelegentlichem vogel
geschrei
kein wunder dass man an horrorfilm oder
missglückte experimente denken muss
[Musik]
diese verfallenen häuser erinnern ans
militär
als wären dort soldaten zur verteidigung
der küste stationiert
[Musik]
ein düsterer ort der heute verlassen und
verfallen ist
[Musik]
doch was hat sich einst ihr abgespielt
wer durch diese flure geht fragt sich
unweigerlich was ist hier los wozu die
großen eisernen türen mit den schweren
verriegelungen war hier ein gefängnis
oder was
warum wurde diese künstliche insel
angelegt und wozu dienten die gebäude
im jahr 1892 wird auf ellis island ein
aufnahmelager für immigranten eröffnet
allein am ersten tag kommen 700
einwanderer aus allen teilen der welt
[Musik]
zwischen 1892 und
1954 durchlaufen um 12 millionen
immigranten das lager im gepäck die
dringend benötigte arbeitskraft
zahlreiche kulturen und sprachen
aber das ist nicht alles was sie
mitbringen
amerika hatte seine tore geöffnet das
klingt großartig hatte aber auch seine
schattenseiten
niemand dachte daran dass der
einwanderer auch krankheiten
einschleppen würden
niemand wusste ob sie infiziert waren
eine klinik wurde dringend gebraucht
1902 eröffnet ein krankenhaus das ellis
island immigrant hostel es ist amerikas
erste verteidigungslinie gegen
eingeschleppte erreger und eine der
größten staatlichen kliniken in der
geschichte des landes
ihre hauptaufgabe besteht darin die
ausbreitung gefährlicher krankheiten zu
verhindern
[Musik]
die leute glauben ellis island sei für
die einwanderer die hölle gewesen
wahrscheinlich hatte das lager auch
etwas furcht erregendes aber in
mancherlei hinsicht war es sehr
aufgeklärt und moderne
ein top modernes krankenhaus mit großen
kapazitäten und gut ausgebildetem
personal
john mcguinness von der organisation
save ellis island will das historische
erbe bewahren
nach seiner eröffnung arbeitete das
krankenhaus mit den modernsten mitteln
es sollte die bevölkerung der
vereinigten staaten aber auch die
einwanderer vor krankheiten schützen
die medizinische einrichtung ist so groß
dass eine zweite künstliche insel neben
der immigranten sammelstelle errichtet
wird
[Musik]
der damals in helles island ankam musste
sich einem sicherheits und einem
gesundheitscheck unterziehen die
mediziner brauchten große fachkompetenz
um all die tests durchführen und
korrekte diagnosen stellen zu können im
grunde war es die geburtsstunde des
amerikanischen gesundheitswesens
1898 wird die zweite insel aufgeschüttet
am ende wird sie sechs hektar groß sein
aber wie baut man überhaupt eine insel
mitten im wasser
die inspiration dazu kam von den alten
römern sie waren so schlau zwei reihen
aus holzstämmen anzulegen die
zwischenräume mit lehm zu verstopfen und
dann das wasser abzupumpen
so entstand ein trockener innenraum den
mann füllen konnte
der holzrahmen wird mit bauschutt aus
der frisch ausgehobenen new yorker
u-bahn aufgefüllt
[Musik]
auf der neuen insel entstehen sechs
hospital worten kostenpunkt auf den
heutigen wert umgerechnet über
23 millionen dollar
ab 1902 werden hier immer mehr
einwanderer durch geschlossen
die meisten von uns werden schon bei der
passkontrolle am flughafen nervös aber
verglichen mit der angst der
neuankömmlinge auf ellis island ist das
gar nichts wir waren vielleicht ein paar
stunden unterwegs sie dagegen
verbrachten mehrere schreckliche wochen
auf einem schiff vermutlich sprachen sie
kein englisch da kann man sich die angst
und unsicherheit auf beiden seiten gut
vorstellen
1907 kommen über eine million menschen
nach ellis island
der medizinische komplex ist überfordert
um raum zu schaffen aber auch um
ansteckende krankheiten besser unter
kontrolle zu halten wird eine dritte
insel angelegt
die aufteilung auf mehrere inseln hat
einen guten grund
damals glaubten die mediziner dass
erreger sich nicht über größere
wasserflächen hinweg ausbreiten können
[Musik]
island wurde in erster linie als insel
errichtet um den komplex von der
nordamerikanischen bevölkerung zu
isolieren so konnten ansteckende
krankheiten gar nicht erst übertragen
werden
[Musik]
jedes der 17 gebäude ist auf bestimmte
krankheiten spezialisiert
der bereich für ansteckende infektionen
kann bei bedarf abgedichtet werden so
wird die ausbreitung tödlicher erreger
verhindert
sie wurden zum beispiel in so eine
abteilung gebracht vermutlich eine
station für männer die betten standen
rundherum jeweils zwischen den fenstern
die architektur geht auf eine theorie
von florence nightingale aus dem jahr
1860 zurück danach gab es in der luft
eine krankheitsverursachende materie der
sogenannten jasmar das unbedingt
vertrieben werden sollte von drei seiten
musste frische luft rein kommen dazu
sonnenlicht diese großen fenster dort
blieben das ganze jahr über einen spalt
breit geöffnet
etwas besonderes sind auch diese
vorsprünge an der decke sie erleichtern
die luftzirkulation die luft steigt nach
oben sammelt die erreger ein und lässt
sie auf der anderen seite aus dem
fenster
1860 war das eine fortschrittliche
theorie
[Musik]
es ist das zeitalter von tuberkulose und
cholera kontrolle und sauberkeit sind
von äußerster bedeutung
in der hauseigenen wäscherei werden 3000
handtücher und laken pro tag gereinigt
es gibt sogar einen riesigen stählernen
druckbehälter den sogenannten autoklav
in dem matratzen mit heißem dampf
sterilisiert werden das personal trifft
alle denkbaren vorkehrungen um
kreuzkontaminationen zu verhindern
die räume wurden verschlossen die
menschen blieben während der behandlung
etwa drei wochen lang hier
antibiotika stehen kaum zur verfügung im
grunde wird nur abgewartet ob die
patienten wieder gesund werden oder eben
nicht dem was uns furchtbar gewesen sein
die leute wussten dass man sie zurück
schickt wenn sie nicht gesund wurden zum
glück schafften es die meisten nur ein
prozent alle ankömmlinge muster aus
gesundheitsgründen zurück nach hause
das krankenhaus auf ellis island ist
alles in allem ein großer erfolg mit den
jahren aber wird es vom medizinischen
fortschritt überholt das hospital muss
schließen
[Musik]
danach wurde ellis island vorübergehend
vom fbi genutzt später wurden dort
kriegsgefangene untergebracht
für eine weile war es also noch in
betrieb doch dann wurden die türen für
immer geschlossen
1954 werden das lager und das
dazugehörige hospital aufgegeben
jahrzehntelang sind die gebäude dem
verfall preisgegeben
[Musik]
inzwischen aber bemüht sich die safe
eines eilen foundation um die
restaurierung des krankenhauses und
organisiert besichtigungen
[Musik]
die einwanderungs station ist eine
populäre touristenattraktion
das benachbarte krankenhaus ist aber
nicht zugänglich dabei war es genauso
bedeutend wie das aufnahmelager es
symbolisiert das vermächtnis des
amerikanischen gesundheitssystems
[Musik]
2000 meter hoch in den französischen
alpen befindet sich ein rätselhaftes
bunkersystem
[Musik]
hier errichtet solche riesigen anlagen
ein großer teil davon unterirdisch sieht
aus wie das werk der zwerg aus herr der
ringe ein
labyrinth aus trostlosen gängen die tief
in die berge hinein führen
[Musik]
warum wird so was so weit oben gebaut
wozu dienten die burka in dieser kargen
einöde und wie lange stehen sie schon
leer
[Musik]
in den 30er jahren entwickelt sich
deutschland wieder zu einer bedrohung
die franzosen haben den ersten weltkrieg
noch frisch im gedächtnis und wollen
ihre grenze absichern sie errichten ein
komplexes verteidigungssystem die
berüchtigte maginot linie
es war ein befestigungs labyrinth über
und unterirdisch seiner zeit galt es als
das non plus ultra der militärischen
verteidigung
[Musik]
die maginot-linie ist weder eine mauer
noch eine linie sie geht mehr in die
tiefe es gibt panzersperren abschnitte
mit stacheldraht beobachtungsposten herz
die chinesische mauer ist das nicht ihr
ein vielschichtiges verteidigungssystem
in der gesamten grenzregion
die verteidigung ist ein wichtiger teil
der gesamtstrategie
das ist wie beim boxen du schlägst nicht
nur zu du musst dich auch schützen
die franzosen errichteten die maginot
linie um auf den nächsten deutschen
angriff vorbereitet zu sein
[Musik]
auch ein anderer nachbar der sich mit
hitler verbindet hat könnte zum angriff
übergehen
italien unter benito mussolini
die franzosen trauen den italiener nicht
ein krieg zwischen diesen beiden
wichtigen europäischen nationen ist im
bereich des möglichen
wer traut schon mussolini
[Musik]
in den dreißiger jahren eskaliert
allmählich die spannung zwischen
frankreich und italien
deshalb verstärken die franzosen ihre
verteidigungslinie an der grenze in den
alpen
[Musik]
nur wenige kilometer von der
italienischen grenze entfernt auf dem
kamm dieses gebirgszugs steht der
höchstgelegene bunker der maginot linie
[Musik]
sein name frasch die reste von
auch ein relativ kleiner vorposten wie
dieser kann in den alpen von großer
strategischer bedeutung sein
die festung sicherte die bergpässe mit
artillerie selbst im sommer war es für
mussolinis truppen praktisch unmöglich
auf diesem weg nach frankreich
einzudringen
die bauarbeiten beginnen im jahr 1931
sie entwickeln sich in jeder hinsicht zu
einem logistischen alptraum
die bunker wurden tief in den berg
hineingegraben auf bis runter zum
fundament die französischen bauarbeiter
standen vor großen organisatorischen
problemen sie mussten schweres equipment
und den beton rauf in die alpen schaffen
solchen herausforderungen zum trotz
entstehen echte abwehrbollwerk
sie bestehen aus stahlbeton das heißt
der beton wird über stahlgitter gegossen
die konnten eine menge aushalten ohne
nachzugeben
wie können bunker in dieser höhe
betrieben werden wie viele männer werden
hier stationiert und über welche
zeiträume
die festungen mussten sich selbst
versorgen sie brauchten ihren eigenen
strom ihr eigenes wasser sie mussten an
das haben was nötig war um hunderte oder
sogar tausende soldaten durch den
strengen winter zu bringen
also nahrung krankenstationen
schlafräume und alles unterirdisch
geschützt vor bomben und artillerie
die lüftungsanlage schützte die soldaten
nicht nur vor gas angriffen sondern auch
vor den diesel dämpfen ihre generatoren
und den gasen ihrer artillerie geschütze
im mai 1940 werden frankreichs
befürchtungen bestätigt deutschland
startet seinen westfeld zug und wird
dabei von italien unterstützt die beiden
länder haben 1939 den sogenannten stahl
pakt geschlossen
[Musik]
der witz krieg ist im vollen gange und
frankreich bleibt nichts anderes übrig
als seine militärischen ressourcen an
die schlachtfelder zu verlegen einige
stützpunkte in den alpen bleiben und man
zurück andere werden von unerfahrenen
soldaten bewacht
die maginot-linie war wie gemacht für
schlecht ausgebildete rekruten mit wenig
erfahrung sie mussten zumeist nur simple
aufgaben erledigen
mit hilfe der fortschrittlichen technik
der maginot linie sollten sie
frankreichs grenze verteidigen
heute wissen wir dass das bürgernetzwerk
in frankreichs höchster festung nie ganz
vollendet wurde
der bau der maginot linie dauerte mehr
als zehn jahre als der krieg ausbrach
waren einige abschnitte noch nicht
fertig
kann die unvollendete verteidigungslinie
den angriffen der deutschen und
italiener stand halten
[Musik]
nachdem die nazis bereits große teile
frankreichs erobert haben greift
mussolini am zehnten juni 1940 an
die italienische armee verfügt über
zahlreiche alpini gebirgsjäger die für
den kampf in den bergen perfekt
ausgebildet waren
[Musik]
es gibt nur wenige geeignete pässe die
durch dieses unwirtliche gelände nach
frankreich führen
die franzosen wissen also ganz genau
wohin sie ihre waffen richten müssen
selbst eine kleine festung kann eine
straße durch die alpen für die angreifer
unpassierbar machen
alles musste so ausgerichtet sein dass
sie den feind aus verschiedenen
richtungen unter beschuss nehmen konnten
[Musik]
in diesen räumen stand einst ein ganzes
sortiment an maschinengewehren
granatwerfern und schwerer artillerie
heute erinnern nur noch die dachkuppel
man die waffen von damals
[Musik]
die kuppeln über den maschinengewehr
stellungen bestanden aus dickem stahl
selbst die 88 millimeter geschosse der
deutschen schafft es kaum sie zu
durchdringen
die maginot linie hält der italienische
angriff wird abgewehrt
[Musik]
die festungen hielten stand sehr zur
schande der italiener die sich trotz
zahlenmäßiger überlegenheit einer
handvoll französischer soldaten
geschlagen geben mussten
[Musik]
aber es ist nur ein etappensieg der sich
schon kurz darauf als bedeutungslos
erweist
nach nur anderthalb monatigem kampf
zwingen die deutschen am 25 juni 1940
frankreich zur kapitulation
[Musik]
für die italiener ist der weg durch die
alpen jetzt frei
wenn die franzosen reste vw geplant
fertig gestellt hätten hätte es auch
einen größeren italienischen angriff
standhalten können
christoph hat seine schuldigkeit getan
auch für deutsche und italiener ist die
festung nutzlos sie wird in den bergen
zurück gelassen
heute ist das in die alten gehauene
bollwerk immer noch ein mahnmal das an
den zweiten weltkrieg erinnert
[Musik]
überraschte restaurant ist ein dokument
französischer baukunst und
militärtechnologie
es hat jahrzehnte überdauert und wird in
einigen hundert jahren immer noch da
sein
es ist etwas besonderes
ein wunder der ingenieurskunst
[Musik]
sie zählten zum fortschrittlichsten was
ingenieurs und baukunst zu bieten hatten
heute sind sie nur noch ein echo der
historie sie erzählen vom krieg und
terror aber auch von den großen erfolgen
der forschung und des menschlichen
strebens
[Musik]